what's up everyone Persia here and today
we are going on a few island tours of
our own I had the chance to visit for it
inspiring and gorgeous islands and
animal crossing new horizons and we are
about to hop over to the very first -
let's get to it
so here we go I am going to star means
Island I'm going to poopoo right now so
star me I actually have her in the call
with me hi guys so a little bit of a
like a introduction to my Island it is
themed it's more of a rave it's not
complete yet but even like to my
villagers I'm choosing ones that look
like they're going to a rave oh my gosh
okay now you're starting to bum me out
Patrick
so this present actually is a gift from
stymie to one lucky person in the
Commons I don't know what's in it
it's wrapped I'm not gonna open it if
you comment down below you're gonna have
a chance to win star Mia's a special
prize so we could start off with the
house okay you could go in first
oh snap walking in like it's my house
I'm just kidding I love the floor the
floor is great the Imperial floor I
don't know did you do you find sure your
house um no it's a mess ever since I
started frustrate you know you got the
green on the bottom we got Reds on the
right and you got on the left old stuff
or yellow cardboard works as well but it
actually does increase your look wow
that is a mean yeah well I did catch a
little knowledge being dropped right now
courtesy oh sorry I mean I just left
first I'm like is uh oh I'm gonna call
it art I'm gonna call it art yeah take
this how you will guys I had nothing to
do with it this is the function a stuff
like this is not oh gosh gotcha
I wanted the all-black bathroom so I
knew this was everything okay so the
vibe the omnia
right now right Jim lights and
everything didn't like the steam on the
floor
I love it yeah you hear that yeah I
wanted to it gold everything but it also
have no schools he look like there's
nothing in the room oh yeah I can tell
by how this looks against the wall so
this is my lab oh I love the music like
on plaintiff thank you thank you I think
music really is important this is not
organized but I purposely made it like
that because if I had a lot it also
would not people yeah it's like mad
scientist and they either smoking me
over here it's a lot unlike my last
crack I'm so close sorry I'm just
walking through it again because I might
not ever be surrounded by such luxury I
was debating whether to do a whole
basket report or not I wasn't sure like
I've seen some really cool QR codes I
mean this to Larry because he still got
the lines at least this area is so fun
I wanted it to originally be in my house
but I realized that that our cage things
take so much space yeah yeah it takes
like a lot of space like I just got all
the colored seats and I'm gonna
eventually decorate that [ __ ] I love the
instrument area with the moon the moon
is so pretty I really love ya start
recipe if you stand in front of the moon
and go up I guess like if you look up
I tried to create I tried to create in
center the oh yeah they're full of
behind it alright so we're gonna we're
gonna go to the rave well that's your
biggest inspiration for making this rave
so like I was supposed to go to EDC you
see was in is this month like I was just
like two weeks for my bachelorette party
but you know things are things and I was
like you know I'm gonna create etc' in
my game just straight ahead yep oh my
gosh oh my goodness it's already so
colorful yeah I tried I love this I'm
ready well awesome thank you so much
star me and you know you guys can follow
star me on Twitter and we are on to the
next I live
[Music]
all right everybody we're heading it to
an amazing tour actually because it's
themed after the happiest place in the
world
Disney Pete what's up thank you so much
for allowing this tour having me
yeah I'm excited so let's get in some
Disney casual yes oh my god it's
beautiful yeah I made try to recreate
like a garden area at the front here
which was a lot of fun to do I try to
make it as brightness colorful as I
could so it's actually Caicos sliders
here giving a concert you know what
Disney without the entertainment so
they've hired KK for the day VIP guide
VIP so this is my main street area oh my
god this is actually what they call the
high area and you got the promo in there
ah I know I knew people would be
probably want to take pictures so I was
like I'm gonna stick my name is with
this part here I we have a in
Fantasyland and just in front of the
cars behind the castle they have a sword
in the stone right I don't have a sword
in a stone but I have a golden axe in
the ground so if anybody manages to pull
it out they get to keep it okay I didn't
have the power
oh yeah this is I try to make my house
look as much like the Disneyland Paris
castle so there's more like a pink
facade and then like a blue door and
blu-ray Thanks yeah and it's a very
castle like door also I love it it is I
tried to make it look as much as I could
oh I'll be the same as you if you're
doing that I'm gonna do it yeah there we
go
Cinderella so yeah over here we have
like some of the rides
of course it's like what is it the
Fantasmic hat
oh yeah the yes every occasion yeah we
go let's go follow Mickey I wish we
could have it years ago so we have a
little wishing well here yay I love a
use the stand up like mountains and
stuff because I know it's very yeah
thing for the background and then we've
got like a little thing don't touch this
your fall asleep yes
so welcome to Tomorrowland or
discoveryland and we've got like 8000 I
love the UFO it's a little I do I love
the little alien yep big talk is one of
my other villages and is in like a
little racing you know various right
yeah racer so I thought he would be
perfect to have an Autopia themed house
so I made him a little oh my gosh it
honks when you get on oh I didn't know
that the lights come on yeah so I did a
lot of custom Czech checkered line and I
love that there's like concessions like
everywhere here and there because that's
exactly exactly you need to get your
snacks so this is going into
Frontierland oh my goodness I love it
already but you can tell it just might
be aesthetic and everything that we are
here this is legit giving me like
flashbacks because like the rushing
water sound from the waterfalls and
everything but really adds to it every
sound that you can actually see the
Haunted Mansion just looming oh yeah I
love it so I didn't know how to do like
the house and then I was like hang on if
I use a second account I can actually
make a spray on my island today
- and I love that people have been doing
that morning because it really does add
because the way you can customize the
house is like it's is perfect
exactly so now I can make a nice wookie
house alright that concludes our tour of
wabi-sabi land thank you so much P for
letting us do this tour it was magical
it was magical if you're not absolutely
inspired to give your islands a glow up
after that and be sure to tune in to
part two of this video because it's
going to be sure to do the trick
catch us next time
[Music]